The Aquaman movie is finally on its way to
being a real thing.
The solo adventure for the DC Comics character
rolled out its first full trailer, and the
result has people feeling more excited than
they thought they could ever be over a superhero
who can talk to fish.
The movie's long-awaited first trailer provides
the clearest look yet at what we can expect
from the murky depths.
Here are all the details you may have missed
from the first Aquaman movie trailer.
The Trench
One of the trailer's most exciting shots involves
Jason Momoa's Aquaman and Amber Heard's Mera
diving into the ocean to escape a swarm of
monsters.
This evil group chasing after the Atlantean
heroes are members of a society known as the
Trench, who were first introduced in a 2011
Aquaman comics run by writer Geoff Johns,
who has a story credit on the film.
Formerly Atlanteans themselves, the Trench
are a splinter sect that was formed when the
legendary city sank into the sea, with their
group falling deep into the Marianas Trench.
While the rest of the surviving Atlantis population
adapted to undersea life and maintained their
humanoid looks, the Trench became monstrous
and cannibalistic, adopting savage methods
of hunting and marauding in order to survive.
Led by their own King and Queen, the Trench
serves as a dark mirror image to the other
prosperous Atlanteans, sea monsters who are
some of the more formidable dangers of the
deep.
Vulko
One shot of the trailer lingers on a teenaged
Aquaman or an Aquateen, if you will training
in the art of catching a spear in between
his hands, a move he puts to good use as an
adult.
That training sequence also offers a short
glimpse of Willem Dafoe's character, Vulko,
in action.
According to Dafoe, Vulko is essentially Arthur's
mentor figure, being 100 percent Atlantean
while Arthur is half human and was raised
on the surface.
They're characters with a lot of comics history
together, with Vulko serving as Arthur's regent
after he takes the Atlantean throne.
Swim good
A big moment in the Aquaman trailer is his
explosive arrival on a submarine.
"permission to come aboard."
But what you might have missed is Aquaman's
approach to the submarine.
It only lasts about a second, and shows Aquaman
super-swimming his way toward the sub, a skill
we haven't really gotten to see him show off
in his earlier movie appearances.
Regardless, it's a power he's long had in
the comics, being able to swim at the rate
of 6,800 miles per hour.
Home invasion?
The other big highlight of the trailer is
Black Manta, or if you're not a longtime comics
fan the guy in the evil SCUBA suit.
Beyond having one of the coolest looks in
the entire history of comic book movies, it
looks like the Aquaman rival will play a part
in some deeply personal drama.
In the Geoff Johns comics from which Aquaman
partially takes inspiration, Black Manta gets
hired by a doctor named Stephen Shin to acquire
a blood sample from Aquaman as a boy, in a
bid to prove that he's something more than
human.
The pursuit ultimately results in the hero's
father's death.
In the trailer, Black Manta is seen in full
combat mode in a domestic location.
As the only surface-side household we see
in the trailer, it's tempting to think that
this set piece takes place inside of the lighthouse
home of Aquaman's childhood, which would spell
pretty terrible things for the one non-superpowered
member of his family should Black Manta get
his hands on him.
Unite the Seven
In addition to giving audiences an idea of
what they're in for on their journey under
the sea with Aquaman and friends, the Aquaman
trailer finally gave moviegoers an answer
to a question that's been lingering out there
for years.
Specifically, after all this time, we finally
know the meaning of the phrase "Unite the
Seven."
The very first image of Jason Momoa's Aquaman
came in February 2015, more than three years
before his solo movie's release date.
That image was superimposed with the phrase
"Unite the Seven."
At the time, and for years after, no one was
really certain what this phrase was meant
to convey.
As it turns out, the tagline refers to what
appears to be the general plot of Aquaman,
with Arthur's half-brother Orm working to
unite the seven kingdoms of the ocean into
one unified force to take on the surface world
in all-out war.
"And I'm bringing the wrath of the seven seas
with me."
Just talk
Another aspect of undersea living that a lot
of people don't think about is communication.
Justice League had Mera use her control over
water to create an air bubble for the purposes
of conversation.
Luckily, that weird, potentially drama-crippling
solution isn't being brought over to Aquaman's
solo outing.
Director James Wan confirmed
as much on Twitter, writing, "Fret not, no
'air bubbles for dialogue' in my underwater
world."
So how do they talk underwater in Aquaman?
The answer, as the trailer confirms, is that
they just can.
Sometimes it's best not to overthink things.
"That was the worst pep talk ever.
Nereus
The trailer for Aquaman sets up a lot about
the movie, even though it doesn't linger too
long on everything it introduces.
One of those quick glimpses appears to introduce
Dolph Lundgren's character Nereus.
We don't know much about what Nereus will
get up to in this movie, but we do know that
he's been substantially altered from his comic
book counterpart in at least one way.
In the comics, he and Mera were in a relationship
in the movie, they're evidently father and
daughter.
Yellow eyes
As played by Jason Momoa, the Aquaman of the
movies has typically been shown as having
some mystically pale eyes.
But one pivotal moment in the Aquaman trailer
appears to be a whole new invention for the
character the yellow shade that young Arthur's
eyes turn as he communicates with the sea
life in the aquarium.
It'd be understandable to think that those
yellow eyes come straight from the comic books,
but that doesn't seem to be the case.
Most likely, it's a movie invention meant
solely for the audience to understand when
Arthur's revving up to throw a pile of sharks
at his enemies.